[Music]
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
this morning Disney released this short
little teaser trailer for their Disney
Plus streaming service that is coming
out in November now they did this only a
few days before the Disney d23 Fan Expo
which is from August 23rd to the 25th
and it is widely believed that there is
going to be some pretty big Marvel
announcements at the d23 event of course
a lot more information and some reveals
about Marvel's series that are coming to
Disney Plus such as wand vision Loki the
Falcon in the Winter Soldier and it's
also believed that Marvel will talk a
lot more about phase 5 during the d23
event at the end of San Diego Comic Cons
Hall H panel Kevin Feige on stage said
that he didn't even have time to talk
about Black Panther to Captain Marvel to
the mutants come in to the MCU and the
Fantastic Four come in to the MCU and
blade of course
[Applause]
in communion we didn't mention the fact
that guardians galaxy 3 is coming you
have time to talk about Captain Marvel -
I didn't even have time to talk about
the Fantastic Four
[Applause]
there's no time left to talk about a
mutant
so it's widely believed that they're
going to talk more in depth about these
films that were mentioned and of course
about future projects coming to the MCU
and Disney Plus so let's go ahead and
break down all that we know about the
Disney d23 Expo all the rumors and what
we can expect to see real quick if you'd
like a chance to win an Xbox one or a
ps4 be sure to subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment below with
your favorite superhero or villain so
you can enter my giveaway I'll be
picking a winner at 500,000 subscribers
so again one of the biggest things that
everybody is anticipating is a possible
reveal of phase 5 at the d23 Expo this
has been rumored and heavily speculated
about for a while now and there are
reports saying that Marvel is going to
announce something really big really
soon now that doesn't mean it's about
phase 5 and that doesn't mean it's going
to happen at the d23 event however it is
a perfect time to do it and as far as
big announcements go phase 5 would be
the biggest announcement that we could
get but there are also rumors for more
announcements coming there was actually
a report that came out and I did a video
on this stating that we could be getting
a Hulk series on Disney Plus the reason
for this being is because Marvel doesn't
own all of the rights to the Hulk they
can't use the Hulk in a solo film only
in group films like The Avengers or Thor
Ragnarok but it has been stated that
Marvel isn't done with the Hulk so
moving forward how do they continue the
Hulk story arc and if they want to make
his story aren't just about him how did
they do that well they do a Disney Plus
series with him it's kind of a loophole
because it's not a movie but a series
would allow Marvel to only focus on the
Hulk story and even though Marvel does
get their own time to talk at the d23
Expo the most likely only focus on the
Disney Plus shows they don't get 90
minutes like they did at San Diego
comic-con the time is much shorter and
since Disney is advertising Disney Plus
right before the d23 event they will
most likely focus on those Disney Plus
series so the announcement of a Hulk
series would be a big one there is also
talk of a Miss Marvel series possibly
coming to Disney Plus as well Kevin
Feige has said that Miss Marvel is going
to be coming into the MCU but these
Disney Plus series are going to be in
the MCU everything that will happen
in the series will effect what happens
in the movies so they could introduce
her first in her own series and of
course at the event they could introduce
entirely new shows that we haven't even
thought of or heard about yet there's
speculation that we could possibly get a
moon night show and really there's just
so many different characters that Marvel
can make a show about so the d23 event
is going to be really exciting
regardless of whether or not Disney does
their huge announcement then we're still
going to find out a lot about the future
of the MCU at the event so let me know
what you think this big Marvel
announcement is going to be and do you
think we're going to receive it at the
d23 event let me know in the comments
down below also don't forget to comment
with your favorite superhero or villain
like this video and be subscribed to my
channel so you can enter my giveaway for
a chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 and
so you can stay up to date on everything
we relating to the MCU don't forget to
follow me on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof